hi everyone good afternoon how's
everyone doing this is really bright I'm
so excited to be here today
my name is omni i'm the co-founder and
CEO of poppy we're building the modern
village by connecting vetted caregivers
to families when they need childcare I
started poppy not because I'm an expert
in the field or because I have a deep
passion for childcare
I started poppy for two people these two
the older is my daughter saya and the
younger is my daughter aria
I was so tired of feeling panicked and
anxious every time I wasn't a thousand
percent sure of who was taking care of
my girls and I couldn't believe that so
many of us are dealing with this every
single week and then I couldn't believe
that all the people all the amazing
people that are taking care of our kids
they need more recognition and
opportunities so I decided to build it
with poppy so I decided to build it with
poppy we're serving thousands of
families in Seattle right now and it's
incredible thing to be a part of
especially because poppy almost didn't
exist one of the reasons I'm so excited
to be here today is because two years
ago I sat in your seats at the 2015 SFC
I sat there and I listened to all these
incredible women telling their stories
about bold visions and amazing companies
and I desperately wanted to be like them
only in that moment nothing seemed
further from reality I was in the middle
of shutting down my first startup after
spending years working on it and sinking
thousands of my own personal dollars
into it I was so ready to give up and
just head back to my successful career
in brand management only this afternoon
just inspired me so much and I headed
back and I decided to give it another
shot but not only that I set a goal and
this is a little bit crazy but this is
my journal from that night and I said
crazily in 2017 I want to be on that
stage giving the talk
stead of sitting in the audience thank
you
so when cat sent me this email asking me
to be one of the speakers you'll notice
the date and says April thirtieth I was
so honored obviously because this was a
goal and it was just one of the biggest
parts of my story to actually try again
but the other crazy kind of ironic part
was that she had sent me a different
kind of email two years earlier and this
one was when she told me and she crushed
my dreams and she told me that YC wasn't
going to be funding poppy and so this is
the story I want to tell you a little
bit about today what happened between my
first failed startup and poppy which is
funded and growing today and what
happened between cats first email and
then me standing in front of you today
my hope is that maybe you'll learn a
little bit from my mistakes
but I hope that in hearing my journey
you'll be able to connect it to yours
and figure out a way to start and then
just keep going so my sort of journey
starts about five years ago I had my
first daughter and I was struggling to
figure out a way how to pass on my rich
Indian heritage and the traditions on to
my girls a friend and I started talking
and we thought well we could figure out
our solution to this it was the time of
about twenty twelve so subscription
boxes were all the rage and so we
thought well if we just curate something
you know it could do as culture Na would
we have the language and food and all
these amazing things why couldn't we do
that and so we worked on it we worked on
the side while we still kept our jobs
and we build business plans and
financial models for two years we worked
on it on the side then finally in March
2014 we both decided we were going to
quit our jobs and work on this full-time
it felt incredible but at the beginning
it was what are we going to focus on
well I'd heard all of these things about
MVPs and working on product and getting
it out and so we worked on the product
and we
he thought about what we would want to
have in this box and we figured it out
in three months we were able to put this
beautiful curated box together of things
that we thought were going to solve the
problem because that's what we wanted
and we thought that was exactly what
you're supposed to do so in June we
launched and it felt incredible we had
friends and family everyone texting us
and emailing us and saying wow this
looks amazing
we even had a bunch of orders and so we
thought this is amazing a few weeks go
on and the orders start to trickle a
little bit they slow and we're like that
I mean it's a little bit concerning but
we think you know that's probably just
because we don't have enough product so
let's work on more products and get them
into the shop so we work on that now
it's the fall and we're quickly running
out of money we had both invested about
$20,000 of our own savings and we had
figured if we launched then we'll just
be able to raise money then it'll all be
wonderful that wasn't the case and we're
so we were quickly running out of money
we decided to try everything we possibly
could we did Facebook campaigns we did a
google adword campaigns we even went and
partnered with some of the best brands
out there like the tea collection just
trying to figure out how we could
kickstart growth and get people to buy
this amazing box that we had done after
the holidays it became clear that it
wasn't working the cost of acquiring
these niche customers was just way too
high and it didn't make sense for the
one or two boxes that they were buying
so we made the hard but right decision
to shut it down I don't think we talked
about this enough but this is some of
the hardest times of my life I felt like
a failure I felt like I let everyone
down including myself and I had lost
money that our family could use for the
mortgage and the nanny and college funds
I couldn't really see my way forward the
worst part was is that I didn't know why
I failed I think it's one thing to make
a wrong decision or a wrong term but I
think it's another thing to not learn
from it and so where do you go when you
need to figure something
the Internet I started reading
everything I could about how to start a
startup or how do successful startups do
this and I came across a whole slew of
holograms essays and how to start a
startup from YC and I devoured
everything and I started to realize to
some of the ways that I might have been
thinking about this in a little bit of
the wrong way instead of following your
passion you know this whole concept of
living in the future and building what's
missing
whole idea of talking to your users
instead of other folks and just building
using that to build your product and
then I love this one but just finding
the hundred people that really loved
what you were doing versus focusing on
everybody else that were out there and
then the simplest but hardest one I
think was just grow 10% every single
week just grow based on this I thought
you know what this is the blueprint that
I've been missing the whole time and I
wanted to try again by this time I'd
come to the female founder conference
and I was so inspired and I decided I
needed to try again so I started talking
to parents parents that had bought some
of our boxes parents that were just in
the neighborhood
I talked to them and I asked them if
papaya and Post if this box is not what
you need and it's not solving a big
problem then what are some of the big
problems in your life I think you'll
find if you've ever worked on a product
that people just don't really need you
start you have this real intense drive
to then work on something that everybody
needs and so the topics just kept on
coming back to child care and I couldn't
believe it because I mean I lived that
with two careers and two kids and no
family in town like my husband and I
would just wake up every morning and
hope we didn't have to do the calendar
shuffle you know the thing where you
know your nanny text said 7:00 a.m. says
I'm sick and then your husband pull out
your phones and said okay if I can move
this meeting I'll take the morning and
you can cancel that and I'll take the
afternoon and it's [ __ ] and the fact
that so many of us were doing this for
me was just it just caught my curiosity
and I wanted to figure out what would it
take
to fix it and sure this is one of the
most crowded categories you can find out
there and so I had a lot of people
saying are you sure this is what you
want to be looking into but for me it
was that if it was solved if all of
these people were doing it then we
wouldn't have such pain over here and as
I started talking to different people I
realized that the thing that they didn't
need was apparent connecting to a center
the thing that wasn't being said was
that we were all missing our village
everyone says it takes a village to
raise a child but with all of us moving
around for our careers and our jobs
we're all missing our village and so I
thought well how do you recreate
something so human and so emotional as
village was something so rational as
data and code
well I found my undergraduate degree in
chemistry coming back to me and I broke
it down into a tidy equation I thought
if village is a function of trust
someone you trust is a fit for your
family and is available when you need
them to be then could i approximate it
with something that provides vetting a
matching algorithm of some sort and then
a scheduling mechanism it started to
come all together in my head and I could
see how this could be a beautiful app
there's only one problem I wasn't then
and I'm not now a programmer and I
really struggled for weeks I tried to
figure out how can I build this without
a programmer I'd spent the twenty
thousand dollars that I had devoted to
startups and I had about $200 left in my
business bank account not enough by the
way to pay a programmer to build you a
now and so I was a vote to give up
because I mean what are you supposed to
do and in the dark of footing my
five-month-old to sleep you know it
takes a long time there's a lot of time
to think it came to me SMS
why couldn't I use SMS because parents
and sitters are already using texting
too and so like when I use that to
approximate the experience so I sat down
and I wrote out the whole flow and I
tried to figure out
if I could somehow approximate the
experience using already available tools
and tools that were either free or had
free four-week trial periods so I could
stretch my two hundred dollars for just
a four week test to see if I was onto
something
so this is my tech stack I had a landing
page on Squarespace signups and feedback
so where it forms word Unser type form
stripe handled the payments I did
scheduling via Google Calendar
communication with with SMS and my
database was Excel so I could see how
all of this was going to come together I
got to work finding and vetting three
University of Washington students and I
found 15 families in my local
neighborhood on a posting board that has
just posted about needing child care I
sent them an email and I just said hey I
know you need child care I've got these
three amazing people if you need someone
this week just text this phone number
and I gave them my personal phone number
that day I got my first booking and that
week I got my first for every single
week I just set the goal to see if I
just could just grow ten or twenty
percent
well that next week instead of just five
I hit six week after seven the week
after ten I was blowing past these ten
twenty percent of week goals I can't
tell you how different that felt versus
my first startup and the whole time I
was trying to push this boulder up the
hill and this one it was just parents
were telling other parents and it wasn't
easy by any stretch of the imagination
but it just felt different the end of
the four weeks as luck would have it why
see was accepting applications for their
summer summer 15 batch and so I thought
what the hell I'm going to apply because
I knew I was early I knew I didn't have
a co-founder and a team but I also knew
that I was building something that
people wanted so I applied and truth be
told I didn't put a lot of Hope into it
because I had applied for my first
startup I'd sent weeks writing the
perfect application I didn't even get an
interview
I'd also heard that YC was the place for
that 23 year old white programmer
which clearly I'm not but still I
applied because I believed in those
truths that I'd read in some of those
essays so imagine my shock when I got
invited down for an interview excitedly
got all ready and went down for my
10-minute chance and I sold my heart out
to cat Kevin and Erin nonetheless at the
end of the day I had this email waiting
for me in my inbox and I'd be lying if I
didn't say I was disappointed but the
next day I woke up and I decided to
focus on that last paragraph the one
that said we would love to see you
reapply next batch and I focused on two
things one they thought I was on to
something and that if I just showed more
growth and brought a team on that I
could reapply and the second thing was
regardless of what YC thought or said I
had a growing company and I had growing
I had customers to serve so I got to
work I pretended as if I got into IC
anyways and I set myself the goal to
just grow by 10 to 20 percent every
single week for that whole summer
parents would text my phone number and
asked me you know hey is someone
available tomorrow from noon to 4 I
would consult my high tech day planner
and I'd see who's available and I text
the sitter and then I'd text the parent
back if you want to know what my first
product looked like
I'm almost embarrassed to show this but
if you can see in the left-hand margin
the numbers that are circled that was my
goal so every single time I hit the goal
and in the boxes were all the bookings I
don't remember what the color coding was
- this is crazy but this is all I needed
to get this up and off the ground and
then I started to Ogura the day planner
shocking I know
and so I moved on to excel again it was
super simple and it was just enough to
get the job done by now I knew that we
were continuing to grow and I knew that
I had to find that technical partner to
help me build this but it's not as easy
as it might sound and I'm sure there's
some of you out there that are you know
struggling with the same thing about how
to find that perfect co-founder there's
a reason that YC says not to start
working with someone that you've just
met you're trying to find someone that
is a good complement for you and it's a
good fit with your personality somebody
has the right experience and can have a
passion for the mission and then finally
can be a partner in the trenches through
the ups and downs it's a pretty tall
order so I talked to everyone I asked
for every single intro to any engineer I
talked to tens hundreds of people and
still nothing I know is about August and
I was exceeding my ability to just do
all this on my own
and the crazy ironic thing was I was
about to grow my company to death I
couldn't handle any more and so I
doubled down and I asked it kept on
asking people for more intros finally
through a friend of a friend of a friend
I finally met Richard and when I met him
what struck me was that our backgrounds
were really different but the thing that
connected us was that we had both spent
our career in pursuing the things that
made us curious
he'd been really interesting but
different things he'd worked on a social
media company a dating app and a Bitcoin
gambling company which I know what
you're thinking is the perfect match for
my wholesome family company
but when I started talking to them there
there was just a fit it was just easy we
would just connect on what the vision
was and how this could all be built and
it wasn't until later that I actually
realized his experience was just perfect
what is poppy if not building community
when there's a matching algorithm
involved and we're definitely taking
payments but in those early days it was
really just a leap of faith and all of
this is just a leap of faith so we
decided to just work together for six
weeks just like a project and see how it
would go he built the first version of
our platform in a way that was just more
nuanced and more sophisticated than I
could have even imagined and in that I
found a partner to be able to build
poppy in October we decided to make it
official we even hired our first
employee Sarah she actually comes from
the childcare industry and so she was
tasked with the most important part of
our company which is finding those
really amazing care givers where they
are what they what kind of experience
they have what kind of vetting needs to
be done so she came on and joined the
team I'd always thought of poppy as sort
of a three-part thing there's a parent
side there's a sitter side and then
there's the text that connects it
between it we now had the team finally I
felt like we were getting some momentum
we had the team we had the ability to
build the platform now though we did
have any money I couldn't believe I was
in since position again this time we had
payroll and we had just the regular
expenses of a growing company and we
needed cash as luck would have it
winter ycs winter 16 application was
just open and so we reapplied and this
time the application basically wrote
itself I mean we had done everything
that YC it asked us to do and more than
that we just pretended as if we had done
YC and we just continued to grow we had
even more users that loved what we were
doing we had the team so we were so
excited when we again got the chance to
interview
Richard and I practice all the questions
and we made our way down to Mountain
View I knew that the hardest part of our
application was the fact that we had
only worked together for three months so
it was prepared for those questions what
I wasn't prepared for though was that as
we were walking in to register for the
interviews in behind us walked the
founders of our key competition I walked
into the restroom to just gather myself
and I thought we had just come too far
to just quit and I thought if I was
going to go down I was going to go down
swinging
no so we got in there and we just told
the partners about poppy but what we
were building about what we saw about
our growth but our how our users just
loved what we were building and needed
it and then about our team and how we
were the perfect people to build this we
walked out and I didn't know how it was
going to go but I knew that we had given
it our all I hopped on a plane because I
had to get back and I checked my email
like a lunatic just waiting for that
inevitable rejection email by the time I
got home it was just gone in time for
bedtime and I figured you know what what
will be will be and I got ready to just
take get my kids ready and with her
pajamas and I heard the phone ring
YC wanted to fund us I didn't really
hear the rest but it was a stay of
execution I knew that we had bought the
time to be able to figure out the next
thing and his luck and hard work would
have it a seed VC firm and Seattle also
decided to fund us so the week before
heading into YC that was the bank
balance in my business banking account
and my brother over the holidays asked
me why weren't you more happy excited
celebratory and it didn't hit me then
that the money is not something
celebrating it was more relief because
the money buys us time and time to run
those valuable kind of experiments and
to be able to figure out the next thing
so we started YC and even when you find
reprieves they're only temporary so we
just focused on putting our heads down
and just continuing to grow I talked to
the users and parents and Sarah just
kept the great caregivers coming and
Richard just built the product slowly by
slowly we kept on growing by demo day
sure we had the really nice growth curve
but more importantly woven into our
company's DNA we had this really nice
two-week drumbeat of building and then
hitting a goal building and then hitting
a goal our company still has that drum
beat we still use that loop that
two-week loop of building and advancing
we closed our seed round shortly after
demo day a little bit over two million
dollars and we went came back to Seattle
in May and we moved into our first
official offices and I remember being
just so grateful that after all of that
we now had this incredible team and we
had the money and most importantly we
had the time to be able to just work on
poppy and prove what it could be so is
it all roses now definitely not every
day our job is to build something that
people want as measured by our growth
every day we're working on just growing
the company and putting our heads down
even now there's things that we're
working on that I can't see how it's
going to all work out but I know that if
we return to our roots of talking to our
users and starting with just something
really small and then iterating our way
forward we're going to figure it out so
I wanted to leave you with the five
lessons that I've learned between my
first startups and my second the first
is when you're skint just getting
started you're trying to figure out is
this an idea I should be working on and
I think you should ask yourself whether
it's passion driving you or
ASSA tea and frustration the tricky
thing about passion is that it can make
you confident it can make you feel like
you know the answer but with curiosity
it keeps you humble and it keeps you
asking the questions and frustration
just gives you the motivation to get
going in the beginning being a founder
as I'm sure so many of you guys know is
lonely
you need to talk to people but just
which people in the very beginning
because we are both first-time founders
we thought you know what we're going to
talk to the experts we're going to talk
to advisers and investors and people who
have been in the startup space here's
the thing you're trying to do something
that's never been done before there are
no experts the only way you can do this
is by talking to your users and then
iterating your way forward inching
forward product I've talked about this
so I but I can't emphasize it enough
building a start-up is not about
building a product it's about solving a
problem so the product can be far from
pretty and definitely far from perfect
it just needs to be the thing that can
solve the problem when it comes to
funding I think I approach that my first
startup a little bit more like my big
company days I thought of it like a
budget to spend so was it really a shock
when we ran out of money relatively
quickly I now know that the money is
just this valuable time to run these
experiments these experiments are
hopefully so that you figure out a way
to get to either profitability or to
showing the things that you need to to
be able to raise that next round gets
that next level the last thing is about
focus as founders I think this is the
hardest thing what do I focus my time on
in the early days of my first startup I
thought it was all about product
launches and then something tangible and
I could do that but I since realized
that it's all about growth you need to
pick that one metric that is just so
important for your company and then
decide to grow it just consistently week
by week
for my company that's bookings filled if
I if I if we are built at growing our
bookings filled number then we're doing
our job
that means we're bringing on more great
sitters we've got a lot of great
families and we're connecting them
together really effectively so pick your
one number and choose to grow it
consistently the thing that I want to
end with is that I think you guys as
founders have two really important jobs
the first is to start and the second is
to keep going I know how hard it is to
start and then stop and then start again
and I know how daunting it can be but my
challenge to you if you haven't started
can you find a four week period this
summer and just commit just try to
launch something and see if you can grow
it by 10 20 percent every single week
the second is to keep going I applied to
YC three times before getting in papi is
my second startup I am standing here on
the stage because every morning I choose
to be a founder I choose to keep going
and I know for someone if so many of you
you might be in a place that you're not
sure whether you can just keep going and
there's just so much adversity and
there's so many setbacks but part of it
is on you to figure out how can you just
keep going and part of that that makes
that easier is you have to find your
people I definitely would not be here
today if not for my incredible team that
has devoted their days to join me in
this journey to build this thing but for
me personally it's also about my family
my husband my kids my parents and our
incredible nanny for me they're the ones
that enable me to create the space for
me to be the founder that I need to be
so if you guys are in anywhere in the
similar situation you need to find your
people and
your own village so that you can create
the space to be the founder and keep
going it's been an incredible three-year
journey so far and if there's one thing
that I know for sure it's that the world
needs more female founders two years ago
I sat in your seats with nothing more
than a desire to be a founder there's
nothing special about me and I am proof
that if you set a goal and you start and
you choose to keep going then you'll
figure it out
thank you
[Applause]
you